it's been a terrifying and exhausting
journey
but more than 260 ukrainian refugees are
now safe in portugal
president marcelo rebel de souza and his
delegation were there to welcome them to
their new home it
the best response is to see their eyes
shining with joy when they arrive in
portugal it's this help that we give
that motivates us the most
portugal recently approved a new
resolution simplifying its entry and
protection requirements for ukrainian
refugees fleeing the war
under the new measure ukrainian citizens
can obtain legal status with immediate
access to taxpayers social security and
national health service numbers
we as an association will give them
psychological educational human food and
medical support so that they can start
to integrate into society and build
their lives here in portugal
the european nation is home to a large
ukrainian community of around 30 000
people
programs are being put in place to help
integrate new refugees including
language courses and job skills training
the government has set up a task force
to match ukrainians with work
opportunities with more than 17 000 jobs
already listed
and with portugal's low number of
working population this might just prove
beneficial for the nation and its new
guests
chilean wolf al jazeera